[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
und marietta slomka
eine der nachrichten die heute
aufhorchen ließen war der rücktritt
eines russischen uno-diplomaten er habe
sich noch nie so für sein land geschämt
sagte er mit blick auf den angriff
russlands auf die ukraine das ausmaß der
lügen in der russischen außenpolitik sei
katastrophal wenn ein hoher beamter so
etwas über sein land sagt scheint das zu
bestätigen was viele vermuten dass
zumindest nicht die gesamte russische
elite hinter diesen krieg steht doch auf
eine macht dämmerung in moskau zu hoffen
dafür hat vor allem die ukraine keine
zeit ihr präsident selensky sprach heute
vor dem weltwirtschaftsforum in davos
sein publikum eine welt elite die vor
den trümmern vergangener entscheidungen
steht darüber habe ich vorhin mit robert
habeck gesprochen zuvor berichtet anne
gellinek aus davos die ukraine hat den
ersten tag des weltwirtschaftsforums
gekapert es herrscht reger andrang im uk
haus auf der davoser promenade
das land hat eine riesige delegation
entsandt und sein präsident darf als
erster sprechen wolodimir selensky weiß
mit jedem auditorium umzugehen in diesem
saal sitzen politiker die sanktionen
beschließen und wirtschaftsbosse die sie
aushalten müssen also fordert er
maximale härte gegen russland
wir brauchen ein öl-embargo alle
russischen banken müssen blockiert
werden ohne ausnahme
sanktionen gegen den it sektor und der
gesamte handel mit russland muss
gestoppt werden solche maßnahmen würden
einen überzeugenden präsident fall
schaffen für die kommenden jahrzehnte
dafür bekommt er stehenden applaus
obwohl alle wissen dass das öl embargo
noch längst nicht beschlossen ist und
die europäer weiter darum ringen vom gas
ganz zu schweigen fast zur gleichen zeit
in einer nahe gelegenen turnhalle treten
die klitschko brüder auf und plötzlich
ist der krieg ganz nah
witali klitschko der bürgermeister von
kiew spielt den täglichen luftalarm ab
den er mit seinem handy aufgenommen hat
sein bruder wladimir der ehemalige
boxweltmeister zieht einen sport
vergleich
ich habe eine sache gelernt als athlet
ausdauer schlägt talent und stärke
ausdauer ist das was wir brauchen um ein
für alle male unsere demokratischen
werte in der ukraine zu verteidigen
die lenski ist noch nicht fertig er weiß
dass das publikum milliarden schwer ist
und kommt mitten im krieg zum
wiederaufbau der ukraine
privatwirtschaft und regierungen sollen
sich beteiligen und zwar jetzt schon
wir müssen den aggressor bestrafen
russische investitionen immobilien
assets die über die ganze welt verstreut
sind müssen aufgespürt und eingefroren
werden und in einen fonds überführt der
allen hilft die vom krieg betroffen sind
enteignungen sind nicht gerade populär
auf dem davoser treffen doch beim
wiederaufbau sieht sich auch der
deutsche wirtschaftsminister in der
pflicht
vielleicht ist das ein noch eine große
anforderung für viele unternehmerinnen
unternehmer da jetzt wieder komplett
zurück zu gehen das land ist der im
krieg ist wird beschossen
risikolos ist das alles nicht aber
natürlich müssen wir uns damit
beschäftigen und die die vorbereitung
und auch die ersten schritte tun die
ukraine hat den tag in der wurst
beherrscht nur abends ist es auf der
promenade so wie immer da werden noch
schnell geschäfte gemacht am ende eines
langen konferenztages in den bergen
und der bundeswirtschaftsminister ist
uns aus der wurst zugeschaltet guten
abend herr beck
guten abend lang als der ukrainische
präsident residenz g heute seine seine
rede vor dem weltwirtschaftsforum hier
da gab es auch wieder sehr viel applaus
aber was bringt ihm eigentlich diese
applaus wird das wasser am ende fordert
nämlich ein absolutes energie embargo
gegenüber russland dann doch keine
mehrheiten findet
nur da hat ja in dieser rede auch einen
ganz anderen akzent gesetzt und der war
tatsächlich neu nämlich wiederaufbau und
wirtschaftshilfen und das finde ich ist
die eigentliche botschaft schon seiner
rede auf das embargo gleich nochmal ein
aber dass die ukraine die hoffnung will
und die hoffnung heißt das land wieder
aufzubauen und das ist natürlich auch
einen anspruch und die anforderungen an
den rest von europa noch an deutschland
das heißt ich habe dann seine
stellvertreterin hier getroffen wir
haben intensiv darüber gesprochen welche
projekte man jetzt nach vorne bringen
kann welcher auch jetzt notwendig sind
und das werde ich also wenn ich wieder
in deutschland bin und mit druck
voranbringen nur so schlimm das klingt
bevor man einen wiederaufbau denkt muss
dieser trick da erst mal beendet sein
und aus sicht der ukraine gewonnen
werden und da spielen die forderung nach
einem embargo gegen russland eine ganz
große rolle aber bisher können sich die
europäer ja wieder bei gas noch bei
einigen
da ist es auch kompliziert ist habe ich
das schon mehrfach erläutert ein
öl-embargo wiederum ist in der in der in
greifbarer nähe würde ich denken es gibt
noch wenige staaten die da probleme
anmelden vor allem ungarn ich würde auch
einmal einräumen dass die länder
unterschiedliche abhängigkeiten haben
zwischen ungarn und portugal gibt es
halt einfach eine andere verbindung zu
russland klarerweise aber die
rücksichtnahme kann man machen dann muss
allerdings auch in lungern was passieren
und die gespräche werden ja dauernd
fortgesetzt heute die
kommissionspräsidentin also ich denke
innerhalb von wenigen tagen werden wir
doch den durchbruch erzielen sie haben
ja vorgeschlagen eine art ja käufer
kartell zu bilden sozusagen auf der
gegenseite des angebots kartell
man weiß nun dass kartell und absprachen
und sich an höchste sprach absprachen zu
halten immer ziemlich kompliziert sind
ist das realistisch und finden sie dafür
mitstreiter
nun ein embargo von öl
führt nicht automatisch dazu dass putin
geschwächt ist wir haben ja gesehen als
die amerikaner ihr öl embargo verkündet
haben sind die ölpreise global
hochgegangen putin hat also in den
letzten
wochen weniger öl verkaufen mehr
einnahmen gehabt das sollte natürlich
vermieden werden einerseits haben wir
die hohen energiepreise über die ganze
welt hohe inflation eine menge länder
leiden darunter und da ist die idee dass
man sich abspricht und sagte zahlen hier
nicht mehr jeden preis natürlich eine
die helfen würde das ist hier nicht ist
natürlich eine ungewöhnliche maßnahme
sind aber auch ungewöhnliche zeiten und
daran wird auch gearbeitet diese dies
funktioniert allerdings nur wenn sehr
viele länder mitmachen sonst hat man
immer ausweichbewegungen und daran
hapert es bisher noch aber die
europäische kommission und die usa
arbeiten genau an diesem vorschlag das
ist eher ein problem das eigentlich sich
jeder dann doch am ende selbst der
nächste ist sie saßen heute zum beispiel
einem vertreter indiens auf dem podium
indien erweitert gerade seine ölimporte
aus russland aus und wir deutschen
kaufen mächtig viel gas
ja aber da muss man natürlich auch ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein klar kann man
jetzt zu ihm hingehen und sagen leute
warum kauft ihr jetzt öl aus russland
und dann sagt mir der indische öl
minister weil bei und 45 grad sind eine
hungersnot und einer industriellen droht
was soll ich denn tun und ich muss ja
mein land am laufen halten also bei
allem muss man natürlich ich würde es
genau andersrum erzieher nicht mein
indien könnte auch sagen das ist ein
konflikt in europa weit weg von uns
warum müssen wir jetzt unter den hohen
energiepreisen der hohen inflation
leiden weil ihr eure position durch
drückten sie aber nicht sie wollen
solidarisch mit uns sein allerdings
nicht um den preis dass irland
zusammenbricht und insofern so ist
politik nun einmal muss man jeweils auch
immer die andere seite sehen und gerade
indien bemüht sich wirklich mit europa
mit deutschland
zusammen zu kommen und eine energie und
handelns partnerschaft aufzubauen und
wenn ich das noch kurz sagen darf diese
partnerschaften neu zu etablieren eine
neue form eine nachhaltigere eine
gerechtere eine form von julie sierung
zu schaffen das ist als ich das
oberthema hier dieser tagung von der
wurst und das ist auch dringend not wenn
ich wenn er aber sich nur um ihr eigenes
land kümmern bei diesem bei diesen
partnerschaften von denen sie sprechen
dann tauschen wir ja auch so ein
bisschen die russischen oligarchen gegen
scheichs aus katar ein oder haben
abhängigkeiten von china also es
irgendwie schwierig wirklich von
partnerschaften zu sprechen die uns
nicht irgendwann in kalamitäten bringen
dazu zwei sachen was ist die alternative
deutschland fährt nur mit öl aus
deutschland nach viel spaß dann werden
wir nicht so besonders weit kommen dann
ist die energiefrage nicht gelöst weil
wir dann alle die autos zu hause stehen
lassen wir sollten uns nicht immer
einreden dass wir auf der moralisch
besseren seite stehen wenn wir
singuläre entscheidungen nicht treffen
wir haben ein problem wir verbrennen
fossiler energien wir produzieren sie
nicht mehr in deutschland sie müssen
irgendwo herkommen und nicht alle länder
folgen unseren wertekodex das ist so
aber wir sind natürlich weltmeister im
verdrängen und finden dann immer
singulär ein punkt wo wir unsere moral
dann aufhängen können manchmal katar
manchmal russland und dann sagen wir
wenn wir das problem lösen da sind wir
wieder auf der hardware moralisch
richtigen so ist es natürlich nicht
sondern wir müssen sehen dass wir
insgesamt zu einer fairen besser
gestalteten welt kommen also die
partnerschaftliche idee schließt mit ein
dass nicht alle länder den gleiche
wertung kann haben wie wir dass wir aber
daran arbeiten zu einem besseren werte
kann und insgesamt zu kommen asbeck dann
geht für das gespräch
bei dem
robert habeck sprach eben ja auch die
sorge vor hungerkatastrophen an diese
bedrohung vor augen hat auch
bundeskanzler scholz auf seiner
afrika-reise dass der ukrainische weizen
nicht exportiert werden kann betrifft ja
besonders afrikanische standen scholz
besucht ein kontinent auf dem der wahl
sowohl russland als auch china sehr
aktiv sind und abhängigkeiten geschaffen
haben ein grund dafür dass sich viele
afrikanische staaten bei der
verurteilung des russischen
angriffskriegs zurückhaltend der große
staat niger gehört allerdings zu jenen
die sich klar gegen russland
positionieren das westafrikanische land
ist nun wichtige stationen der kanzler
weise das passt auch noch in anderer
hinsicht in niger sind nach wie vor
deutsche soldaten stationiert
andreas kienast und klaus brodbeck
berichten
man muss schon ziemlich lang suchen und
ziemlich weit fliegen um einen ort der
hoffnung zu finden im westlichen afrika
genau da will olaf scholz hin über das
wüssten kämpft elia wissen an diesem
morgen die meisten in der deutschen
delegation nicht viel mehr als dass es
heiß sein soll und gefährlich es ist der
erste auslands gruppen besuch für diesen
kanzler der als wehrdienstverweigerer in
die politik kam und sich nichts anmerken
lässt als er heute herauskommt bei der
spezial mission gazelle und ihren
ritualen camp tilia liegt eine stunde
von der hauptstadt niamey entfernt im
niger in dem bittere armut aber noch
halbwegs demokratie herrscht während sie
jenseits seiner grenzen gerade
zusammenbricht die spezialkräfte nigers
haben einen guten ruf das liegt auch an
den deutschen die sie in tillya
ausbilden in einem kleinen eher
unbekannten auslandseinsatz zudem scholz
unbedingt wollte und das ist hier
natürlich deshalb besonders weil es sich
bei diesem land um ein demokratisches
land handelt dass wir die sicherheit der
eigenen bevölkerung der region aber auch
die sicherheit des demokratischen
prozesses gewährleisten filiago scholz
hinwollte ist nicht kiew wo scholz nicht
hin will aber die sorge vor russland
reist auch nach afrika mit im senegal
gestern sucht scholz ersatz für
russisches erdgas im niger heute einen
verbündeten gegen russische söldner und
in südafrika morgen einen neuen
alliierten bisher hat sich das land in
der uno enthalten dass zahlreiche länder
afrikas russlands überfall nicht
verurteilen besorgt scholz unter ihnen
sind staaten wie mali mit denen
deutschland eine jahrelange kooperation
verbindet
und ganz klar ist die wird gegen hat
gerade nicht verbessert das jetzt
dadurch dass jetzt auch russische sollte
einmal die tätig sind umso besser ist
die zusammenarbeit die wir hier vor ort
raum die wenigen misstöne die es mit
niger gibt sind rein musikalisch
[Musik]
so prowestlich so wichtig ist die
regierung in niamey dass sie sich etwas
wünschen kann
[Musik]
besonders wichtig ist für uns mehr
kooperation im bereich bildung da hat
unser land große defizite
man muss lange suchen und weit fliegen
um einen auslandseinsatz zu finden der
unumstritten ist olaf scholz hat heute
zugesagt in fortzusetzen
und jetzt die nachrichten heißt es gibt
neues von den sondierungen in
schleswig-holstein ja schließlich
holsteins cdu will die grünen zu
gesprächen über die bildung einer
schwarz grünen landesregierung einladen
das kündigte ministerpräsident günther
von der cdu in kiel an ende vergangener
woche hatten sich in einem
sondierungsgespräch die spitzen von cdu
grünen und fdp in kiel nicht auf
verhandlungen über eine neuauflage ihres
jamaika bündnisses verständigen können
hier ist nun aus sicht der cdu weiter
gehen soll dazu äußerte sich könnte am
abend nach einer sitzung des
landesvorstandes seiner partei auf mein
vorschlag hin dafür entschieden haben
den grünen ein sondierungsgespräch jetzt
für die durchführung von
koalitionsverhandlungen anzubieten wir
verlieren mit der fdp dann in einem
solchen bündnis einen koalitionspartner
mit dem wir wirklich vertrauensvoll fünf
jahre zusammengearbeitet haben
in einem ersten kriegsverbrecher prozess
hat ein gericht in kiew heute das urteil
gesprochen lebenslange haft für einen 21
jährigen russischen soldaten hin zur
last gelegt wird einen ukrainischen
zivilisten erschossen zu haben
während des prozesses erklärte er die
tat zu bereuen sein verteidiger
plädierte auf freispruch weil der soldat
auf befehl gehandelt habe und kündigte
berufung an
wegen der wirtschaftlichen risiken
infolge des ukraine krieges sollen die
eu schuldenregeln im kommenden jahr
weiterhin ausgesetzt bleiben das hat die
eu-kommission vorgeschlagen und verwies
auch auf die energiepreissteigerungen
und die lieferketten probleme die
defizitvorgaben waren wegen der korona
pandemie im frühjahr 2020 vorübergehend
ausgesetzt worden und sollten eigentlich
ab kommenden jahr wieder greifen die
zahl der geflüchteten menschen ist
erstmals auf mehr als 100 millionen
weltweit gestiegen nach angaben der
vereinten nationen seien allein durch
den krieg russlands gegen die ukraine
bisher 14 millionen menschen zur flucht
in andere länder gezwungen gewesen oder
innerhalb des landes vertrieben worden
auch gewalt und konflikte in staaten wie
äthiopien burkina faso myanmar oder
afghanistan vertreibe viele menschen aus
ihrer heimat so die
us präsident biden hat bei seinem besuch
in japan ein deutliches signal an china
gesendet für den fall einer chinesischen
invasion sicherte er taiwan militärische
unterstützung zu der us präsident
kritisierte zudem chinesische
militärmanöver nahe taiwan peking
erklärte daraufhin in der us-präsident
solle die entschlossenheit china sie
nicht unterschätzen china betrachtet
taiwan als abtrünnige provinz und strebt
eine vereinigung mit dem inselstaat an
und als hätte die welt aktuell nicht
schon genug sorgen unter anderem eine
nach wie vor nicht beendete pandemie
tauchen jetzt auch noch die affen
drucken auf da denkt sich auch mancher
das hat uns jetzt gerade noch gefehlt
noch ein virus auch hierzulande melden
weitere bundesländer erste fälle
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
erklärte es würden jetzt für deutschland
ein dämmungsmaßnahmen vorbereitet was
man über die affen brocken wissen sollte
hat petra neubauer zusammengestellt er
hat das affen pockenvirus in deutschland
erstmals nachgewiesen wo man wölfe vom
institut für mikrobiologie der
bundeswehr bekannt sind zwei
virusvarianten die zentralafrikanische
linie die macht bei zehn bis elf prozent
der menschen einen schweren manchmal
sogar tödlichen verlauf die
westafrikanische variante ist noch mal
deutlich milder da gibt es eine
sterblichkeit von 1 prozent etwa es ist
diese variante die bei allen fällen in
europa auch bei dem patienten in münchen
aufgetreten ist die symptome sind immer
gleich fieber kopf- muskel- und
rückenschmerzen geschwollene lymphknoten
und schließlich hautausschlag mit
bläschen und pusteln schon mit den
ersten symptomen kann man ansteckend
sein der 26 jährige patientin münchen
ist zwar noch in der klinik dem
patienten geht es weiterhin sehr gut er
hat jetzt keine allgemein symptome mehr
kein fieber mehr keine schluckstörung
mehr angesteckt haben dürfte er sich auf
partys oft trifft es menschen mit vielen
wechselnden sexualkontakten affen packen
brauchen die übertragen sich nicht wie
saas corona virus 2 durch feine
aerosolen über große strecken sondern
eben nur über kurze distanz durch
größere tröpfchen oder eben durch die
hautveränderung und können sowohl über
die bläschen als auch dann am ende wenn
die krusten noch da sind diese bläschen
abheilen diese infektion übertragen
eigentlich sind affen pocken eine
viruserkrankung bei tieren die nur
gelegentlich infektionen beim menschen
auslösen und das meist nur in einigen
regionen afrikas nun häufen sich die
fälle weltweit die gefahr einer
massenausbreitung sehen experten dennoch
nicht der mensch ist ein viel wird für
diese packung das heißt die fühlen sich
eigentlich nicht so wohl in menschen und
dementsprechend machen sie meistens auch
nur milde krankheitssymptome zudem
bietet die klassische pockenimpfung die
es in der bundesrepublik bis mitte der
1970 er in der ddr bis anfang der 80er
jahre gab einen gewissen schutz und die
bundesregierung denkt für risikogruppen
über zusätzliche maßnahmen nach
kontakt aufgenommen mit einem hersteller
der eben stoffe spezifisch für die affen
brocken also herstellt es sind auch also
überlegungen im gange wie eine
eventuelle also impfung dann also
stattfinden wurde aber eine prüfung der
allgemeinen bevölkerung ist hier nicht
im gespräch wichtig sei nun die fälle
aufspüren
isolieren und analysieren keine panik
aber doch vorsicht
als die ampel koalition ihren
koalitionsvertrag schloss noch nicht
ahnend was mit dem krieg noch sie
zukommen würde war ja der wohnungsbau
eines der großen themen und damit geht
es jetzt bereits weiter in den letzten
jahren ist die zahl neuer wohnungen
immer zumindest etwas gestiegen 2021 gab
es da nun einen rückgang das
statistische bundesamt bekannt gegeben
bei der haller was bremst da und wie
wird die weitere entwicklung eingesetzt
also interessanterweise an den
baugenehmigungen lag's nicht davon gab
es genug sondern es lag er an der
fertigstellung der neuen wohnungen zum
einen zögern bauherren wegen der
unsicheren lage mit der umsetzung und
zum anderen kommen bauunternehmen auch
schlicht nicht mehr nach zumal das
baugewerbe auch dieses jahr mit enormen
problemen rechnet wohnungsbau bouma de
seit 20 11 wurde jedes jahr mehr gebaut
als im vorjahr nun 20 21 erstmals einen
rückgang und damit deutlich unter dem
ziel der ampel regierung als hauptgründe
gelten lieferengpässe und knappe
rohstoffe gestiegene preise für
baumaterial sowie der fachkräftemangel
am bau probleme die sich dieses jahr
durch den ukraine krieg noch verschärfen
im bau fehlt es im moment so ziemlich an
allem was man für einen neubau braucht
laut bauindustrie verschieben bauherren
bereits projekte oder stornieren sie
sogar ganz zumal auch die bauzinsen
rasant gestiegen sind der blick der
experten richtet sich also immer stärker
auf neue wohnungen im bestand also die
aufstockung bestehender gebäude oder die
umnutzung von bürogebäuden ja vielleicht
ist das ja teil der lösung für ein
großes problem unserer zeit engpässe
beim bezahlbarem wohnraum weil er werde
vielen dank und zum fußball borussia
dortmund hat einen neuen cheftrainer in
den tests in dieser saison technische
direktor des bvb tritt die nachfolge von
marco rose an persisch hatte dortmund im
vergangenen jahr for roses amtsantritt
zum sieg im dfb-pokal geführt erhält
einen vertrag bis mitte 2005 und 20
nach dem erfolgreichen start von
alexander zverev in das
grand-slam-turnier von paris gestern
haben es ihm zwei deutsche damen heute
in ihren ersten matches gleichgetan
andrea petkovic gewann glatt in zwei
sätzen gegen die französin doda und
angelique kerber erreicht die zweite
runde bei den french open seinem
dreisatzsieg gegen magdalena frech aus
polen
die deutsche bahn und zahlreiche
verkehrsverbünden haben heute mit dem
verkauf der sogenannten neuen euro
tickets begonnen verkaufsstellen
automaten und im internet ab erster juni
können fahrgäste mit den monatskarten
bundesweite im öffentlichen nah und
regionalverkehr fahren die sondertickets
werden für die monate juni juli und
august angeboten sie sollen die bürger
entlasten und mehr menschen in busse und
bahnen locken
und zum schluss gehen wir an die schöne
côte d'azur nach kann die fünf
festspiele dort sind ja kein parkett auf
dem deutsche filmemacher sonderlich
erfolgreich sind volker schlöndorff wim
wenders sind bis heute die einzigen
deutschen regisseure die eine goldene
palme ergatterten und das ist bei wenn
das auch schon 38 jahre her der letzte
deutsche film der ist zumindest in den
wettbewerb schaffte war 2017 aus dem
nichts von fatih akin seitdem nichts
also müssen deutsche cineasten auch
dieses jahr wieder tapfer ausschau
halten wo sich zumindest deutsche spuren
oder beteiligungen finden lassen
sabine schulz im wettbewerb der schwede
ruben östlund immerhin ein film mit
deutscher beteiligung auch zdf/arte ist
an bord und iris berben neben
hollywood-star woody harrelson und der
schweizerin zu die männer
drei enkel auf selten ist eine
rabenschwarze gesellschaftssatire aus
der welt der schönen und reichen
auf einer luxusjacht diskutiert der
kapitän sturzbetrunken mit einem
russischen oligarchen über maxl
kapitalismus während das schiff langsam
untergeht
gestrandet auf einer insel kehren sich
die hierarchien um iris berben in einer
mutigen rolle fast ungeschminkt und
recht lädiert es geht ums überleben aber
es geht auch darum wie überlebt man und
wie wollen wir unsere welt auch sehen
die man sich vorher mit einer ungeheuren
leichtigkeit und lässigkeit und arroganz
einfach genommen hat sehr klug sehr böse
und dann treffen wir doch noch eine
deutsche regisseurin emily atef
deutscher filmpreis 2018 für drei tage
in kibera ihr neuer film läuft in der
reihe als sehr trauriger und er spielt
in frankreich glück mehr denn je erzählt
von natur und allen bis vor kurzem ein
glückliches paar doch seit bei er lehne
eine tödliche krankheit entdeckt wurde
zieht sie sich immer mehr zurück und
begibt sich auf eine reise allein wieder
leoni
in der einsamen landschaft norwegens
sucht sie nach klarheit und antworten
auf existenzielle fragen
ich war immer schon fasziniert bei
diesem moment eines lebens das ende und
wo
wir haben so angst von den ungewiss und
und darum
es ist so ein unglaubliches tabu und
unsere gesellschaft darüber zu reden
aber
wir werden das alle nehmen es ist ein
film über liebe abschied loslassen ein
intensiver ein sehr berührender film mit
einer herausragenden hauptdarstellerin
vicky krieps den namen muss man sich
merken kann ist sie auch in dem pin
courage der österreicherinnen marie
kreutzer zu sehen als kaiserin elisabeth
von österreich ungarn nach ihrem
vierzigsten geburtstag sie hadert mit
ihrem alter und ihrer rolle im höfischen
korsett meine aufgabe ist es die
geschicke dieses reiches zu lenken deine
aufgabe ist das lediglich zu
repräsentieren ein neuer moderner blick
der den cc mythos von ewiger jugend und
schönheit gegen den strich bürstet die
geschichte einer rebellion auch courage
läuft in der reihe als sagt erika in
cannes gefeiert wie auch der film von
emily arte
beides filme von frauen weil es film
über eine frau die sich emanzipiert
beides filme vor eine frau
sich von dem was die welt ihr als platz
gegeben hat befreit und beide filme
hätten es verdient im wettbewerb von
cannes zu laufen
[Musik]
ja das war es von uns mit kino geht es
gleich auch weiter mit dem zdf
montagskino und um 23 55 meldet sich
dann gundula gause mit unserem heutigen
update und uns gibt's morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen würde sinn
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend ja finja so heißt das tief dass
uns heute das ein oder andere unwetter
brachte an seiner kaltfront jetzt heute
nacht zieht das ganze aber nach osten
hin ab dahinter folgt kühlere luft und
das bedeutet der rest der woche wird
unwetter frei wir schauen aber jetzt mal
was aktuell im land los ist der radar
film zeigt uns wie über den nachmittag
hinweg immer wieder aus südwesten
gewitter ins land zogen in form dieser
violetten regengebiete und besonders
kräftig hat es dabei das allgäu
getroffen zum beispiel später ist das
dann auch über münchen gezogen aber nahe
des schlosses neuschwanstein gab es wohl
regenmenge von über 40 litern pro
quadratmeter in einer stunde und große
hagel mengen ja was wir noch sehen wenn
wir etwas weiter richtung norden klärt
blicken auch in kassel hat es gerade
geblitzt und gedonnert das ganze zieht
jetzt etwas weiter richtung thüringen
auch erfurt zum beispiel aber keines
dieser gewitter erfüllt im moment die
unwetter kriterien nicht jedes gewitter
ist die automatisch ein unwetter und das
wird jetzt im laufe der nacht auch immer
unwahrscheinlicher das ganze zwar jetzt
in richtung osten schwächt sich aber
deutlich ab ganz im norden und ganz im
süden regnet es sich heute nacht jetzt
ein bisschen ein bei temperaturen
zwischen 10 und 16 grad morgen früh
morgen gibt es dann meist nur noch 15
bis 20 grad also deutlich kühler nur am
oberrhein und richtung brandenburg sind
es 22 bis 25 grad meistens haben wir
dazu ein wechsel aus sonne und wolken
einige schauer gibt die vor allem in
richtung küste im nordseeumfeld sind
dann nachmittags auch kurze gewitter
damit dabei der wind frischt auf aus
südwestlichen richtungen und zwischen
den bayerischen wald und den alpen daher
einen langanhaltenden regen die reste
davon spüren wir auch am mittwoch noch
im südosten der rest der woche der
verläuft einschließlich des feiertages
abgesehen von einigen schauern aber
meist freundlich mit großen
temperaturunterschieden zwischen 14 und
25 grad